ok dingue Sony une marque d'électronique
vient de sortir une voiture alors pas
réellement c'est Sony on a ils ont fait
une Joy venture en fait ils bosse
ensemble pour sortir une bagnole le truc
qui est très sympa à l'intérieur vous
avez plein d'écran que des écrans tous
les côtés même les rétroviseurs et bien
sont des écrans c'est marrant des
petites caméras à l'extérieur au centre
on a un petit rétro central avec un
écran à l'arrière l'éclairage c'est un
écran d'ailleurs on nous montre
Spider-Man c'est vachement marrant la
bagnole a de la gueule ça sortira alors
aux États-Unis je voulais noter en
Amérique du Nord en 2026 pas sûr que ça
arrive en France on a aucune info on se
parle ici de pas moins de 45 caméras et
capteurs intérieur extérieur tout ça
pourquoi bah pour venir analyser la
conduite venir analyser le conducteur
voir s'il est bien réveillé voir si tout
va bien faire également à pas de plus
vers la voiture autonome l'idée là c'est
sympa et ça finira par arriver et puis
bien évidemment puisqu'on parle de Sony
on se parle de divertissement on se
parle notamment de films de jeux avec
PlayStation pas que donc on va voir
arriver tout un côté divertissement avec
des écrans à l'avant mais également à
l'arrière tout ça très cool je vous dis
une fois de plus pour ce projet dans le
futur est-ce que ça arrivera chez nous
allez savoir la première voiture de Sony
et elle s'appelle à celui-là d'ailleurs
dites-moi ce que vous en pensez dans les
commentaires